When Did We First Use Rubber Ducks?
In 1970, everyone’s favorite orange roommate
sang a song to his bathtime buddy.
“Oh, rubber duckie, you’re the one.
You make bathtime lots of fun,” cooed Ernie
to his squeaky yellow friend.
While the rubber duckie had been around for
at least a century prior to Ernie and his
mellow melody, this Sesame Street tune shoved
the bathtime toy into the popular culture
lexicon where it has remained ever since.
From a chew toy to a piece of art to Ernie’s
best friend (sorry, Bert), here’s the story
of how the world got into the bath with the
rubber duckie.
In 1839, Charles Goodyear discovered vulcanized
rubber.
Legend has it that while in an argument with
his lab partner, he angrily threw a piece
of sulfur-covered rubber into a potbelly stove.
The rubber charred and, then, hardened.
Heat had combined the sulfur molecules to
the rubber molecules, creating a rubbery substance
that was stronger and more elastic.
Whether that’s really how it happened or
not, Goodyear never reaped the financial rewards
that often come with an invention of this
magnitude.
In fact, he died $200,000 in debt, or about
$5 million today.
(See: The Luckless Rubber Maven: Charles Goodyear)
Nevertheless, the vulcanization process and
his subsequent patents changed the world.
By the mid-1800s, products using vulcanized
rubber started flooding the market, including
footwear, sheet rubber, car springs, bicycle
tires and toys.
The first vulcanized rubber toys were available
to consumers around 1850, which included balls,
rattles and doll heads.
It isn’t definitively known who was the
first to make a duck-shaped rubber toy, but
the first rubber squeaky toy of any type was
invented around the 1860s and the first rubber
duck decoy (which was used for hunting) came
in the 1880s.
Rubber toys at this time were nothing like
we think of today.
Hard, unattractive and not malleable, they
were often used as chew toys for teething
babies and dogs.
Like these toys, the early rubber duckie play
item was not meant as a water toy.
As noted by toy scholar, Charles Steiner,
it “was cast, solid and did not float well.”
It also was most certainly not bright yellow.
As the Industrial Revolution engulfed the
country, an increased percentage of Americans
held factory jobs.
Moving from rural America to urban cities
in search of these jobs, the American urban
population grew rapidly.
In 1880, 8.4% of Americans were living in
cities, but by 1890, that percentage increased
to 12.7%.
Living space was limited, so several generations
of family often lived together.
This had a direct effect on many normal family
activities, including bathtime.
Noting this, former curator at a Pittsburgh’s
Toonseum, Joe Wos, claims that the rubber
duck became affiliated with the bath because
it was the only way to get kids in the tub.
According to his theory on the origin of the
rubber duckie as a bathtime companion, on
Saturday nights, everyone in the family would
bath for Sunday church, attempting to rid
themselves of the dirt and grime of the previous
week’s work.
Of course, there was only one tub with limited
water.
Dad would go first, then mom, then the oldest
siblings and so forth until, as Wos explains,
”then you get down to the littlest ones,
they’ve got to go into that dirty, filthy
water that the whole family has used, so you
need a way to get them into the tub – and
suddenly the tub becomes playtime.”
Whether you hold to Wos’ speculative theory
or not, it isn’t difficult to see how a
toy duck, whether it floated or not, would
inspire kids to start playing with it in the
bathtub, regardless of how dirty the water
purportedly was.
Nevertheless, it would be several decades
after this era before rubber duckies would
hit the mainstream.
One of the first relatively popular rubber
duck toys came about in 1938 when the Seiberling
Latex Products Company partnered with the
newly popular movie studio Disney (who had
just released to great fanfare Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs a year earlier), debuting
a line of rubber figurines, including their
character Donald Duck.
Made from solid rubber, like incarnations
before it, this rubber duck was not meant
for water play.
rubber-duckie1A few years prior to Disney’s
Donald Duck toy, a patent was filed by Eleanor
Shannahan of Easton, Maryland for what is
generally considered the first true rubber
duck-shaped bath toy.
While this rubber duckie wasn’t like today’s
version, it provided amusement nonetheless
to “both little children and older persons”
by shooting jets of water at unsuspecting
bathers.
As the patent reads, the duck toy was supposed
to “to produce an attractive fountain-like
effect, and also to enable the playing of
pranks by one person upon another.”
Little is known about the actual production
and sale of this item, but, in 1941, a Los
Angeles artist and sculptor took this basic
design and turned it into a fortune.
rubber-duckie2Even before his creation of
the iconic yellow rubber duckie, Hollywood
artist Peter Ganine was rather famous.
Immigrating from Russia to the United States
on an art scholarship, he moved to Los Angeles
in the 1930s where his work attracted the
attention of longtime Los Angeles Times art
critic Arthur Millier, who helped expose him
to the greater art community.
Ganine hit his apex in the late 1940s when
he began designing toy sculptures, like a
giant grinning whale and a bright yellow rubber
duckie.
Patenting it in 1949, the patent document
for the “toy duck” was remarkably short
and to the point with the drawings of his
design doing most of the talking – showing
that it floated, squeaked, possessed a goofy
smile and it was yellow.
The design was a hit and Ganine sold millions
of his yellow rubber duckies.
While Ganine later also became famous for
adding Gothic faces to chess pieces, the duck
became his most defining work.
Over the next decades, the rubber duckie became
synonymous with kids’ bath time, with a
major assist from Ernie’s song.
Debuting in 1970, “Rubber Duckie” was
so beloved that it actually landed on the
Billboard charts, reaching as high as number
11 in 1971.
Written by Sesame Street head writer Jeff
Moss and voiced by legend Jim Henson, the
song became one of the show’s defining moments,
even reenacted by Little Richard in the 1990s.
rubber-duckSince then, the rubber duckie has
had several other pop culture moments, like
when 28,000 of them were accidentally dumped
into the ocean during a storm (to this day,
there are still reports of people finding
them around the world).
There’s also been several occurrences of
a giant yellow inflatable duck making appearances
in major cities, including stops in Hong Kong,
New York and Syracuse.
And so it is that for over a century now rubber
ducks, in one form or another, have joined
us for bathtime.
Presumably the now iconic yellow duckie will
continue to be a mainstay for centuries more.
After all, they are kind of fun to play
with while taking a soak.